[موسيقى]
اسمي كارتر دنكان
، أنا كبير الطيارين في منطقة البلطيق لدينا ، نحن
حاليًا على أي واحد منا 220 في الإصدار 300
من الإصدار الأطول من
طائرة إيرباص 320 ، تستوعب الطائرة حوالي 150
راكبًا نطير على ارتفاع
41000 قدم  ولدينا نطاق
يزيد عن 3500 ميل بحري ، لذا فإن
سطح الطائرة نفسه هو أحدث ما توصلت إليه التكنولوجيا ،
فهو عبارة عن قمرة قيادة زجاجية كاملة ولم
تعد أدوات الاتصال المستديرة بعد الآن يتم عرض جميع البيانات
على هذه الشاشات ، لذا فهي
متاحة لتوجيهنا  وبالنسبة
لأداء الطائرة ، فإن
FMS هو نظام إدارة الرحلة ، ونظام إدارة
الرحلة يغذي
الطائرة بالبيانات إلى أين تتجه
وكيفية القيام بكل ذلك عندما يتعلق الأمر
بأداء المحرك وما إلى ذلك ، لذلك
لدينا  المؤشر رون أثناء وجوده على
الشاشات ، لدي صفحات مختلفة حيث
يمكنني تنفيذ البيانات ، وهذا سيؤدي
بعد ذلك إلى تغذية الطيار الآلي نحو
ما يحتاج إلى القيام به في مراحل معينة من
الرحلة ،
فلدينا تقنية العصا البصرية ، لذلك نحن لا نفعل ذلك
.  ر لديك أي يو  إذا أخذنا
المنظر أكثر من أجهزتنا ،
فإنه يحتوي على صمامات دوارة متحركة مما
يعني أن الخانق تعطي
ملاحظات على الطاقة الحالية ، حيث يتم
ضبط الدواسات لأسفل هنا لتحريك
الدفة وعلى الأرض يمكنك تحريك
عجلة الأنف لتوجيهها  تعمل هذه اللوحة الموجودة في الأعلى
هنا على جميع الأنظمة
التي من المفترض أساسًا أن يتم تعيينها
قبل الرحلة ، في الواقع ، تم تصميمها بحيث
تحتوي على قمرة قيادة مظلمة ، لذلك يجب ألا تكون
هناك أضواء مضاءة ، وإذا لم يكن لديك أي
قواعد غير عادية ، فلا
داعي لذلك حقًا  لتبديل أي شيء
أمامنا ، سنذهب للإقلاع الآن ،
كنا نتأكد من
ضبط جميع اللوحات وفقًا لذلك ، ثم
سنقوم بإعداد FMS ، ثم سنقوم
بتعيين خرائطنا وفقًا لذلك هنا
وأمامنا مباشرة  خريطة متحركة للمطار
هنا حتى أتمكن من معرفة
مكان تاكسي بالضبط في مسار الإقلاع نفسه ،
سنأخذ القوة إلى موضع معين
للتحقق من أن قيم المحرك
مستقرة ثم نظام الخانق التلقائي
سوف أتولى المهمة من هناك ،
ثم باستخدام العصا الجانبية بسرعة معينة ،
سأقوم بتدوير الطائرة إلى
قيمة درجة معينة ، ثم
أكمل الإقلاع ، وفي مرحلة ما على الرغم من
أنني أرغب في القيام بالرحلة بأكملها
يدويًا ، سأقوم بتبديل الطيار الآلي  على
[الموسيقى]
لك